اهلا بكم من جديد ادى حمزه يوسف اليمين
رئيسا لحكومه اسكتلندا ليصبح اول رئيس
مسلم لحكومه في غرب اوروبا ويعتبر يوسف
البالغ من العمر 37 عاما والمتحضر من اصول
باكستانيه اصغر زعيم للحزب الوطني
الاسكتلندي يوسف الذي ادى اليمين مرتديا
الزي التقليدي الباكستاني تعهد بخدمه
الملك تشارلز الثالث بامانه رغم تاييده
المعلن لالغاء الملكيه لصالح انتخاب رئيس
لاسكتلندا كما اعلن يوسف تشكيله حكومته
المولفه من عشره وزراء بينهم
وقال ان الحكومه الاسكتلنديه يجب ان تشبه
الى اكبر حد ممكن الاشخاص الذي او الذين
انتخبوها
واضاف الى كوني اول رئيس لوزاره اسكتلندا
متحذر من اقليه اثنيه انا سعيد لموافقه
عدد قياسي من النساء على تولي مناصب في
حكومه التي تضم مزيجا من الشباب والاعضاء
الاكثر خبره بدوره هنا رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني يوسف في اتصال هاتفي فورا
انتخاب البرلمان الاسكتلندي له رئيسا
للوزراء
وبتقلد حمزه يوسف منصبه الجديد مع
ريتشوناك يكون بذلك اعلى منصبين انتاج
البريطاني لمهاجرين من اصول هنديه
وباكستاني
حمزه يوسف الرئيس الجديد للحزب الوطني
الاسكتلندي مسلم من اصول باكستانيه ولد في
مدينه اغلاسكو يوم السابع ابريل
1985 درس بجامعه وحصل على الماجستير في
العلوم السياسيه سنه 2007 عام 2011 تم
انتخابه في البرلمان عن منطقه جلاسكو عام
2012 تم تعيينه في منصب كاتب الدوله
بوزاره الشؤون الخارجيه والعلاقات الدوليه
عام 2016 تم تعيينه وزيرا للنقل عام 2018
تقلد منصب وزير العدل الى عام 2021
عام 2021 تسلم منصب وزير الصحه والعمل
الاجتماعي عام 2023 فاز برئاسه الحزب
الوطني لسكتلندي
انضموا الينا من لندن عبر سكايب عادل
درويش براسل معتمد في مجلس العموم
البريطاني ومن لندن ايضا الدكتور فؤاد عبد
الرازق الباحث في شؤون البريطانيه
والدوليه اهلا بكم الى بانوراما الليله
سيد عادل درويش بعد مفاجاه سوناك نحن امام
مفاجاه جديده هل هو انتصار للديمقراطيه ام
ان هناك مسائل اخرى حول اختيار الشعب
البريطانيندا الجديد
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه
يوسف
انتخب ضد مرشحتين الاخريتين لانه اقرب
للتعامل مع حزب الخطر لان حزب القومي اقل
يعني ما عندوش اغلبيه بالبرلمان فيعتمد
على سبع اصوات من حزب الخبز هو ذا اتجاهات
ليبراليه اكثر تتماشى مع حزب القدره حزب
الخضر كان هيرفض قضايا اجتماعيه وثقافيه
للمرشحتين الاخرتين وهنا فضل اعضاء الحزب
انتخابه لانه بامكانه العمل معهم ان هو
كوزير الصحه ما كانش ناجح قوي كوزير نقل
مكانش نجح طيب
عبد الرازق هل تجاوز الناخب البريطاني
مساله اصول اي مرشح لاي منصب مهما بلغت
حساسيته اننا فقط الدول العالم الثالث
مازلنا نفكر بهذه الطريقه
مرحبا استاذ محمد الاستاذ عادل درويش في
الواقع
مر الثلاثه التي ذكرتها حضرتك هي امور
متداخله الى حد بعيد بينغماتيه
والديمقراطيه والبحث عن الهويه البحث عن
الهويه لا اعتقد هذا الامر اننا درسنا في
بلد ناشئ يبحث عن الذات فهو تبلور هذا
الامور ولكن الرائي من الخارج ربما يرى في
هذا امرا مستغربا وامرا عجيبا لكن ايضا لا
يجب ان نستبعد الجانب الديمقراطي في هذه
العمليه لان لولا النهج الديمقراطي الذي
تنتهجه بريطانيا سواء بالنسبه لرئيس
الوزراء
البريطاني سوناك او الوزير الاول وافضل ان
نسميه الوزير الاول اسكتلندي هو ليس رئيس
الوزراء هناك رئيس الوزراء واحد هو
ريشيسوناك وهو الذي يعني يهيمن على كل
الاشياء
في اسكتلندا هو الوزير الاول كما هو الحال
في الدول الاخرى بالنسبه لموضوع التداخل
بين هذه المسميات هو تداخل مشروع في
الواقع ولكن التحولات التي شهدها المجتمع
البريطاني اوصله الى هذه المرحله من وجود
هؤلاء الاشخاص بالنسبه لسواء بالنسبه
لكفاءتهم او لاسباب لانه مثلا في اسكتلندا
ليس هناك اغلبيه مثلا باكستانيه كي نقول
انه دفع بهذا الدافع
ولكن الامر يتعلق بشخص الرجل وبتعاملاته
وبسياساته ورغم ان يعني اسهم النقد كما
قال الاستاذ عادل بانه فاشل كوزير صحه
وقيل ايضا كوزير النقل ومن قبل كوازير عدل
لكن ربما هذا لم يوضع على المحك بعد
والتصرفات والامور التي سياتي بها
والسياسات التي ساجلبها هي التي يمكن من
خلالها الحكم على الرجل في هذا الاشياء
يعني وزير
حزب العمال
المعارض
ايضا يقول ان ان هذه يعني خطوه كبيره في
تاريخ
اسكتلندا وهو صديق له ولكنه يتزعم حزب
العمال المعارض في اسكتلندا فاذا هناك
احساس بان هناك تحولا كبيرا حدث في
البنيه السياسيه الاسكتلنديه لهذا الشكل
هو ايضا
اهو ما حدش يعني بيفكر بعدين طريقه حتى من
الشاشه او من المحللين يعني هنا الجنسيه
هي بالمولد وهي ثقافه بريطانيه انا فاكر
لما كان الجدل الدائر في الستينات من
الجامعه وفي السبعينات يعني بدايه عملي
الصحفي كان في جبل دائر بين اليمين
واليسار هل يسمى المجتمع مالتي كالسيوم
متعدد ثقافات ولا مالتي اسمك ولا مالتي
انا كنت طبعا اليسار
انا كنت ماشي معها او من الناس
المتعدد العرقيات المتعدد السلالات واننا
كلنا من ثقافه واحده تقنيه ثقافه
البريطانيه وهي بتشمل كلمه ثقافه وكنا
فيها واحده في اللغه الانجليزيه اللي هي
بتشمل البيئه السياسيه والبيئه الاجتماعيه
الاقتصاديه وان الانسان بيفكر عند
الانتخاب بيجيبه مثلا شعبيه ريشوناك ان هو
عندما كان وزير الماليه وده بالمناسبه
ثانيه اقدم بريطانيا
وهو كمان منصب اقدم منصب رئيس الوزراء
رئيس الوزراء
التكون في 1922
فكان هو ماسك الماليه ودي اعطته نوع من
الشعبيه
هذا السؤال انه غني وبالغ الثراء فانا قلت
الناخب البريطاني بيفكر يكون وزير الماليه
بلغ الثراء وناجح في الاقتصاد ولا شحات
وتعبان منفلس فهي المساله هنا زي ما قال
الاستاذ
عبد الرازق ان ان المساله هنا هي النضج
سياسي في من هيتزعم الحزب ويكسب الصوت
الانتخابي فعندنا هنا قضيتين زي ما انا
تكررت قضيه ان هو التعامل مع القدس
والنقطه الثانيه اللي هو لا يزال يحمل
لواء
حركه الاستقلال الاسكتلنديه القومي
اسكتلندي فدول ورقتين ربحتين في عند الله
في هذا الموضوع ولكن سيد فؤاد عبد الرازق
مع ارتفاع
الجاليات او التنوع الثقافي والحضاري
والاذن الذي تشهده بريطانيا هل هناك اي
تاثير ولو قليل في اختيار مرشحين من وصول
مهاجر
هو في تاثير طبعا لان النسيج الاجتماعي
الفابرك بتاع المجتمع البريطاني تغير
بالفعل يعني يعني
لم يكن بين المتوقع مثلا قم بهذه الهيمنه
بهذا الشكل موجوده من قبل يعني نذكر ايضا
في حكومه جونسون كان عدد كبير من اخطر
المناصب كان يتولاها اناس من اصول اسيويه
او من القمه الناس ثم يجب ان لا ننظر
اليهم مهاجرون لانهم استقروهم من مواليد
حتى هذا الرجل مواليد يعني اسكتلندا وعاش
وتشرف بهذا الماء وبعد كثيرا حتى في
سياساته وبعني مثلا عين يعني ست نساء من
تسعه في الوزاره هذا ايضا فكر تقدمي جدا
بالنسبه هنا قانون الجندريه ايضا وعلي
خلاف ومنظور امام القانون هناك القضيه
التي تهم اسكتلندا والتي توحدها او الشيء
الوحيد في الواقع الذي يوحد في في س
والعرقيه من لندن عبد الرزاق الباحث في
الشؤون البريطانيه والدوليه فؤاد عبد
الرازق شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا ايضا السيد
عادل درويش البراسل المعتمد في مجلس
العموم البريطاني